a cheap-ass news she bail Sheba
submitted by a mother of four not a seed
mother of four that's a lot of kids have
yet to play on the father of four from
New York I'm not that hip to the cool I
only know because I follow cardi B
that's oh yeah music I choose to only
listen to a certain amount of artists
it's good yes yeah yeah listen to me
enough to even know that Oh me no I
don't like any of those guys that much
to be honest cuz like I understand if
they could rap but they haven't shown
that they can and they all have the same
flaw yeah we grew up with 90s music
though you know like we were we were
living in like the golden era of hip hop
and R&B music and you know now you
compare like obviously who out of these
artists are gonna become legends in the
future you Justin Bieber dude exactly
alright then yeah I miss the 80s one my
name is David and I'm here to say I hope
everybody has real good
and it has a little breakdown to a mom
refused to pay her babysitter because
she already got ice cream and easy kids
to watch
oh like the mom already had ice cream
for the kid yeah I guess she ate ice
cream so she thought it was like like my
kids aren't even that hard then you got
ice cream for it so what's the big deal
[ __ ] is a fall camp
hey that's cool you know what I would do
if that happened to me I'd be like oh
really you're right so ones the next
time I'll watch your kids and then I
will watch the next time but I wouldn't
burn that [ __ ] house no no I would
take the kids out okay you're a single
parent no no I need the babysitter I'm
the Beeson I would take the kids out and
I would burn the house and scare the
[ __ ] let me [ __ ] on Noah that [ __ ]
reminds me of though that like that type
of mindset and mentality reminds me of
like how a lot of business people treat
creatives it's like okay I need graphic
design work it's like whoa I mean you're
gonna get exposure that's good enough
for payment right like they don't
respect the type of work it is that you
do like no this is actual all right
especially when when you know in the
creative field when you're really
skilled you can you you're uh how long
it takes for you to do certain jobs you
know and shorter and shorter
yeah for example like the better you
become at editing yeah quicker you Ryan
ever compared to someone that's new at
the job right so then like oh that only
takes you like five minutes to do you're
like like a designer yeah like sketching
something oh not only takes you like ten
minutes you know it's like novel that
[ __ ] took me like years to do like ten
years like why can't you just drop like
a portrait of me real quick that should
only take you 30 minutes yeah and why do
you want to be paid for it I'm gonna
post it I'll share it on social media
you know [ __ ] exposure my 200
followers are gonna see it right right
by the way I pay all my artists because
I believe in that [ __ ] man oh I went to
this random event where they just kind
of invited influencers to get like a
bunch of free [ __ ] you know it's so
interesting how the people like so
they'll have their name tags on them or
but you actually had a person follow you
with your thing so you can get your free
[ __ ] right
and I just out of curiosity was looking
up some of these people and some of
their like sloppiest little girls and
guys I'm like Danny's people must be
huge
8,000 followers said it was like do who
the [ __ ] are you Bob Brown just like
acting like you're the [ __ ] [ __ ]
like what's wrong with you dude and like
for me and like I was talking to my dude
that was that was a that was holding my
[ __ ] and that you he won't let you grab
stuff I think this is job yeah but it's
super [ __ ] massive well I was like
how are some of these people I know some
people are kind of like really snobby
and mean looking them up they're like
really nobodies and but they're so mean
to people like how dare you how dare you
treat these people like that this
because like I think some of them are
like actors so their agents will get
them in there you know they're tied to
an agency they'll get them the biggest
thing and they are influencers and hours
yeah I feel like sometimes they think
I'm a lesser being than them you know
like I don't dress the most hottest we
probably might do get a t-shirt brawlers
oh man I'm just chilling sometimes I
show up in sweats right or whatever
because like the people asked me to and
then we get into circles we get the
conversations people start sharing their
instagrams
you know I show my I ain't even that big
but they're like what like ten thousand
subs I mean or followers good for them
you know they're growing their [ __ ] but
I'm like what's up [ __ ] that's all I
know [ __ ] I'm the best I'm the
best you literally said five minutes ago
that you're nobody no but that's until
he shows them you know okay let that's
right [ __ ] I feel like a nobody in
front of them I feel like they're more
famous because they're acting with it
yeah they're dressed to the T they have
their little cliques and [ __ ] I'm just
there like hi thanks for inviting me
cool we got this swag bag oh yeah
whatever and I'm like I don't feel right
around here
also I don't feel like I fit in because
most of these things that I do go to I
don't even know why I get picked because
like they'll be like either food
Instagram focus or like fashion focus or
sometimes they're like 99% like fashion
women and I'm just standing there like
why am I here you're at the women self
cuz they want to [ __ ] you Joe that's
what I do I don't know about that all
right so the stories about Kristen she
was a babysitter and her brother posted
screenshots of a conversation that she
had with the moms been pissed for her um
to run it so who do you want to be the
mom or the babysitter I want to be the
mom yeah um
role playing Kristin I'm Kristin it was
great watching blank and blank today I
enjoyed them do you mind if I swing by
tomorrow at 2:00 p.m. to collect the
money I wasn't aware it was involved you
got free ice cream and a day of fun I'm
sorry for the misinterpretation why was
buddy even discuss um we discussed
payment of $16.63 me great see you then
sixteen and our sound fair
perfect I'm looking forward to working
with them I'm excited wait oh wait yeah
I won't the other way event great to see
you then $60 an hour sound fair
perfect looking forward to it she said
it yeah yeah she said it blanks seems to
have a knack for you go easy on him haha
I will thank you so much for this
opportunity of course call it text if
you have any questions so I'm resuming a
conversation I delete my messages often
I'm sorry but as much as I love seeing
your kids I'm doing this for payment
exclusively
now she deletes her messages so she
forgot that she's [ __ ] said that
herself yeah so then she says well
you're acting kind of stuck up aren't
you can we compromise at $20 no I
watched her kids for eight hours and we
agreed on 16 an hour
128 dollars is the total Wow and she's
trying to [ __ ] bargain that down to
20 bucks I am not paying you 128 for a
single day they're easy kids you know
what not a discussion of that and I have
text messages for a textbook to prove to
people to prove it please I would accept
a hundred dollars don't even know you do
not accept a hundred absolutely not I
wish I didn't have such a stuck-up cut
watching my kids I'm going to block you
now please oh you wish you call a cop oh
are you serious and then it's a green
bubble now because she got blocked I
mean now she could sue her yeah they're
not Chinese
we give check Chinese people bad rep
sometimes times people never but they
won't do they would never do something
like this never watch they're actually
Chinese give you the money they just
want tip you don't argue with you before
the job is done exactly yeah well
sixteenth Ola my ass this is [ __ ] up
that's like after you ate your meal at
the restaurant when they come up for the
tab you go I didn't like it I don't want
it anymore sue the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
her for the $128 yeah so then people
were asking like wait how did you even
get in contact with this woman like it
seems like she knew her or something oh
that's even worse
so then the brother said that she had
never met the woman before but his
sister has her own babysitting web site
in their town and that's how the woman
contacted her associate Kristen texted
the husband explaining that it would
cost him 128 dollars but if they didn't
want to pay it would cost way more for
for them to go through the small claims
court of course and then they would lose
everything they'll have to pay for her
legal fees and everything else and then
so the husband agreed to pay her 102
- oh my god I wouldn't even do that I'd
be like I would pretend like I didn't
even get any of those messages and I
will still taking the small claims court
just so they could pay more now for
their concept for the Chris technically
if I didn't read it I didn't see it I'm
like oh I didn't actually see this so if
I see text message will you block me so
I don't see it so this is what we're
gonna do on the take you the small
claims court you're gonna pay for my
[ __ ] legal fees and on top of that
I'm gonna get more money out of you so
suck my [ __ ] dick yeah that's yeah I
watch a lot of judge [ __ ] Judy and
judge Mathis and Judge Joe Brown when do
you want judges when do you work this
was when I was younger out with skip
school and I used to watch the view the
worst thing you can do is after you
agree upon services you get it done and
it's in writing and you don't pay
that's violence's that's why
prostitution needs to be legal you know
how many hookers are can you imagine you
suck off this greasy disgusting
[ __ ]
and then afterwards he decides not to
give you your $20 because it's illegal
and then you can't report them you can't
write and he's like I'll give you five
anyway yeah that's why you need a pimp
yeah then you pay because it's a legal
now they ought to rely on that yeah or
brothels and yeah legal they're waiting
the pimp comes in and he lays the
[ __ ] smack now with his [ __ ] pimp
hand it would be this way - yes for the
pro exactly one for the boats and whoa
Wow oh no he would be do would be doing
oh yeah
[Music]